hello and welcome i'm james murphy and
today we're going to be installing
python for data science
why is installing python for data
science any different than installing
python for any other reason
well when you're working with data you
often don't know exactly what you're
looking for ahead of time
you just kind of want to play with the
data and then decide what you want to do
with it later
if you just installed python directly
you're probably not going to have
all the tools that you need in order to
interactively explore data
that's why i recommend that if you're
going to do any kind of data analysis
you should install anaconda which
packages all these common data analysis
tools for you
especially if you're new to python this
can really help because
you don't have to worry about what
packages and things to install
anaconda just comes with all the most
popular ones pre-built in
you don't have to worry about anything
if you are watching this video
most likely you're looking for the
individual edition
so let's download the individual edition
most likely you are running a 64-bit
machine and you should choose the 64-bit
option
it's nearly half a gigabyte big so it
might take a while to download
alright now that it's finished
downloading let's go ahead and run the
installer
click next to continue and accept the
license agreement
i recommend installing just for yourself
that way you won't need admin privileges
by default it's going to install
anaconda into your home directory
note that it's going to take up nearly 3
gigabytes of memory so make sure you
have the space before trying
go ahead and click to go to the next
step
i recommend not adding anaconda to your
path or registering it as your default
python
so leave both of those boxes unchecked
then you can proceed with the
installation
okay it finished that took about five
minutes for me remember it had to unpack
three gigabytes of data
then go ahead and click through the rest
i wouldn't bother with either of these
tutorials
you'll now find that you have something
called anaconda navigator in your system
let's go ahead and run it
this is a dashboard showing you all the
different programs that are either
installed with anaconda or available to
download through anaconda
the one that i recommend using for data
science is jupiter lab
don't get confused with the similar but
older jupiter notebook setup
jupiter lab is similar to jupiter
notebook it's running the same code
under the hood and it's written by the
same people
the difference is that jupiter lab is
designed to be a more all-inclusive
integrated development environment
whereas jupiter notebooks
are kind of just looking at single files
one at a time let's go ahead and launch
jupiter lab
once jupyter starts you'll find yourself
in your home directory
i recommend making a new folder for your
python projects
go ahead and navigate inside the folder
now we can finally create our first
python notebook by clicking on new
notebook
you can rename the notebook by
right-clicking and selecting rene
notebook
and now you can just type python code
into these cells
once you've typed the python code you
can execute it using shift
enter notice that a new cell appeared
below the first one
i can write different code in this cell
and run the cell independently of the
other cell
the state of any variables you assign is
preserved so anything that you do
in a previous cell can still affect
other cells
but i can still go back and run previous
cells again if i want to
i went ahead and downloaded a sample csv
file into this directory
which we can now load into memory so
that we can explore like this
as you can see i can see the data set
and decide what to do next based off of
what i see
i don't need to have the whole thing
planned out already this is the main
benefit
of using jupyter lab you can see the
data and then decide what to do with it
later
go ahead and start playing around with
it yourself now you just need to know
how to effectively
use python for data science but that's a
different video
thank you for watching